in the United States we make just over
half of our electricity from coal and in
most of the
traction is at least that high in places
like China it's even higher and so it's
not realistic to think that over the
next few decades we're going to be able
to dramatically reduce our emissions of
carbon dioxide without continuing to use
make some use of coal in this department
a number of folks have been working over
the years on strategies to reduce and
ultimately eliminate the emissions of
carbon dioxide that come from burning
coal hopefully the work we're now doing
will point the way over the next decade
or two both in terms of technology but
also in terms of regulatory strategy to
figuring out how to begin to decarbonize
the electricity system and
transportation
you